women constitute 70% of journalism and
communication graduates in the EU but
they occupy only 30% of management jobs
in the media this imbalance widens the
pay gap between women and men
MEP s-say media companies should pay
attention to women's advancement they
should offer management training for
women or flexible working arrangements
fo fo Seco Le femme the Sun fat
discriminatory position
dolly ahem innovation dolly coo coo CA
position they director she only position
the management content is also important
media turns to women mostly for opinion
or for personal testimonies and almost
never as experts Parliament wants to
encourage best practices such as setting
up databases of women experts as well as
media campaigns and promoting diversity
citizen for Tom Cooley from so prism
canoe guvo on Town Planner from Nouveau
you Lapham come let's expect that's good
live from usual author quantity in
journalism women are less likely to
cover sports or business and their looks
are given greater importance Parliament
is calling on media companies to update
their internal policies including with
codes of conduct and anti harassment
measures